on continue dans cette émission de vous
donner des clés pour faire votre choix
dans cette présidentielle comme chaque
jeudi je vous propose un coup de
projecteur sur les propositions des
candidats des candidats s'est demandé
programme
[Applaudissements]
demandez le programme consacré au
pouvoir d'achat plus précisément à la
question des bas salaires faut-il
augmenter le smic que propose celles et
ceux qui rêvent de l'elysée les détails
avec jonathan du prix des
préoccupations principales des français
le pouvoir d'achat s'imposent comme
thème incontournable de campagne pour
tous les candidats à la présidentielle à
gauche
revaloriser le smic apparaît comme le
levier privilégié pour réhausser les bas
salaires
2269 euros nets mensuels aujourd'hui
jean luc mélenchon veut le porter à 1400
euros anne hidalgo elle propose 1440
euros
l'écologiste et yannick jadot veut aller
encore plus loin en proposant la barre
symbolique des 1500 euros net idem du
côté des communistes le candidat fabien
roussel promeut même sa mesure sous
forme de jeux de mots leroux seulement
fait augmenter les salaires et les
retraites parce que quand on augmente
les salaires et les retraites c'est de
l'argent qui va aller directement dans
l'économie réelle qui va aller dans les
commerces qui va aller dans nos pme
c'est de rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux
français
les propositions fusent aussi à droite
côté lr valérie pécresse entend
augmenter tous les salaires
progressivement pour atteindre + 10 %
nets sur la durée de son quinquennat une
idée qu'elle compte financer grâce à une
baisse de cotisations vieillesse on
engagement sur le prochain mandat c'est
d'augmenter hors inflation les salaires
nets de 10% jusqu'à 3000 euros une
proposition proche de celle de marine le
pen la candidate du rn prévoit elle
aussi d'augmenter de 10% les salaires
mais finances à mesure par une
exonération de cotisations patronales
cotisations qu'eric zemmour veut lui
aussi allégé pour créer une prime zéro
charge
tout fait pour accorder une prime chaque
année sans aucune taxe ni aucune chat ni
patronales ni salariales
cette prime
présenté jusqu'à 3 2 une promesse qui
rappelle la prime macron créé en 2019 du
côté du président sortant certes pas
encore candidat l'entourage des manuels
macron étudierait selon les échos des
pistes pour aider les branches
professionnelles à réévaluer leurs
minima sociaux à chaque nouvelle
augmentation du smic et on décortique
donc les propositions concernant ses bas
salaires avec mes invités sans drame au
timbre soit vous êtes députée elle et
roem de l'isère vice président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
alessandra dublanche bonsoir
vice-présidente de la région
ile-de-france coordinatrice de la
cellule riposte et comité de soutien de
valérie pécresse amine mbarki bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes secrétaire national
du parti socialiste et vous êtes élu à
montreuil j'accueille également en
duplex en visioconférence and social si
vous soit vous êtes chef économiste au
cabinet bdo bienvenue à vous aussi
laetitia que pas évidemment est resté à
mes côtés peut-être un constat tient
pour commencer celui de l'observatoire
des inégalités qui nous dit que un quart
des salariés français touchent moins de
1500 euros et la moitié moins de 2000
euros sandra moteur
l'insee prévoit une inflation entre 3 et
3 et demi pour cent au premier semestre
est-ce que ça demande une réponse
structurelle au delà des chèques
inflation au delà du coup de pouce sur
les carburants et est ce que
accessoirement emmanuel macron attend
d'être candidat pour proposer cette
réponse structurelle en réalité la
question c'est surtout de savoir est ce
que cette inflation elle est durable ou
est ce qu'elle est conjoncturelle on
sait que toute l'économie mondiale a
repris d'un seul coup très fort on a en
ce moment une inflation qui est
essentiellement lié à des problématiques
de coûts de l'énergie donc finalement
prendre une ré enfin donner une réponse
très structurelles aujourd'hui ça
pourrait être un peu prématuré
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on a rien fait
et en l'occurrence sur les bas salaires
c'est évident il ya un souci on a un
souci en fait en france sur sur ses
salaires qui sont à la fois on pourrait
dire très haut par rapport à une moyenne
mondiale puisque notre smic est l'un des
plus haut au monde mais en même temps
très bas par rapport au salaire médian
c'est à dire qu'on a la moitié des
français qui sont payés entre le smic et
1700 euros
et puis on a la moitié des français qui
sont de l'autre côté et là du coup on
voit qu'on a finalement des gens qui ont
quelque part une espérance dans leur
carrière de à peine 600 euros donc
qu'est ce qu'on a fait nous on a déjà
augmenté on a rendu accessible on a
augmenté la prime d'activité ce qui
passe en dehors finalement des caisses
des entreprises
mais on voit aujourd'hui qui a encore
une attente n'attendent très fort qui
dit qui est logique qui est logique en
sortie de crise et surtout avec le
rebond exceptionnel de notre économie et
donc ça nécessite effectivement des
réponses et peut-être effect aussi des
réponses qui permettent d'accompagner
chaque rebond et vous aurez l'occasion
évidemment de les détailler alessandra
du blanchi valérie pécresse était au
pouvoir tient en ce moment qu'est ce
qu'elle fait différent or ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on peut pas régler les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat à coups de
chèques inefficace et mal ciblés quand
j'entends madame la députée et
dire qu'on peut pas régler sacs des
réformes structurelles je pense que
c'est tout l'un vers ce qu'il faut faire
des réformes structurelles le travail ne
paie pas assez en france on est 12e au
sort en europe et ran pour le salaire
moyen on insère moyen d'à peu près 20 %
inférieur à celui de l'allemagne et donc
il faut rapprocher le salaire net du
salaire brut et donc la proposition de
valérie pécresse comme elle vient de
l'expliquer c'est d'augmenter de 10% les
salaires nets pour les salaires jusqu'à
2,2 smic donc ça à peu près de 1800
euros comment on le fait on lui demande
ce qu'elle a un peu changé pied
changer parce que c'est la cre qui
rentrait plus dans détail de la méthode
justement et c'est sa preuve de sa
crédibilité
elle a changé ni l'objectif ni la
méthode qu'est-ce qu'on fait un coup de
filet mené avec quand même entre temps
mais heureusement qu'on concerte avec
les entreprises et que l'état ne décide
pas des salaires
voilà libéral est donc l'objectif il est
lassé les 10 % les 3 % dès cet été avec
la baisse des cotisations vieillesse
d'entreprise à part l'état et ensuite
effectivement nous c'est notre façon de
gouverner référence aux sept accords
pour mais attendez qu'est ce qu'on met
dans la balance on discute avec les
entreprises qui accessoirement font face
à des problèmes de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dont qui sont aussi fortement
intéressé dans les hausses de salaire je
le pense la libéralisation du temps de
travail la débureaucratisation et on
atteint peu à peu ses 10% bon on suivra
ça amine mbarki la question des
rémunérations alors est vraiment pu être
le marqueur fort de la campagne d'anne
hidalgo puisque ça avait démarré avec sa
proposition initiale de doublement du
salaire des profs le temps du
quinquennat pourquoi ça n'a pas pris
alors d'abord parce que c'était c'est
trop cher n'est pas finançable pourquoi
ça n'a pas pris non il faut distinguer
ce qui relève de la hausse des salaires
des fonctionnaires de ce qui relève de
la hausse des salaires dans le privé
dans le privé on ajoutera du de sa
première proposition oui alors à la lan
marquer l'opinion leur marque fignon il
ya des débats pour il ya eu des débats
contre mais justement on en parle parce
que sights a marqué l'opinion donc oui
le débat est un débat là dessus en
disant est ce que c'est trop est-ce que
c'est pas assez est ce que c'est
différent des autres pays européens il
faut savoir que les professeurs en
france touchent un salaire qui est deux
fois moins important que le même
professeur dans le reste des pays de la
cedeao donc doubler le salaire des profs
c'est pas leur faire une faveur c'est
juste rattraper le retard qui a été pris
et s'assurer de revenir à un niveau de
l' ocde donc ça c'est à mon avis un
débat qui a eu qui est intéressant à
voir parce que il faut qu'on puisse
revaloriser les professeurs et leur
carrière ce après la minorer cette
proposition puisque c'est n'est plus
tous les professeurs c'est les
professeurs qui débute
donc qu'il ya eu il ya un débat c'est
que dans aujourd'hui les enseignants
sont pas rémunérés à la hauteur en
médecin de la fonction qu'il essaie
juste quand on écoute valérie pécresse
et anne hidalgo on voit qu'il ya des
propositions qui sont mises sur la table
et qu'ensuite il ya de rétropédalage
soit parce que les medef passe à gauche
lui ai dit bah nous on n'a pas envie
d'avoir les trois pour cent dans cette
hausse des salaires au soir parce que
finalement
même si un
patient et on n'impose pas des salaires
dans ce pays aux entreprises et donc
évidemment entendu cet argument je vous
laisse conclure il ya un problème sur
les bas salaires en france et je pense
que le débat public est aujourd'hui un
print est une bonne chose l'une des
mesures phares d'anne hidalgo c'est
d'augmenter le smic de 15% pour
s'assurer que il ya un gain de 200 euros
nets par mois pour 4 millions de
personnes en france a quand même
considérable et on y reviendra tout à
l'heure parce que la hausse du smic
effectivement ça peut être une mesure
phare on verra quel quel effet il peut
avoir elle peut avoir cette chose du
smic pardon and social si je viens vers
vous pour revenir sur l'inflation sandra
motta évoqué tout à l'heure mais je
voudrais entendre votre analyse
votre expertise avec une double question
est ce qu'elle est exceptionnelle cette
inflation alors on parle effectivement
là c'est sur le premier semestre l'insee
10 entre 3 et 3 ennemis vous nous
donnerez les chiffres que vous que vous
avez en tête mais double question est ce
qu'elle est exceptionnelle d'abord et
ensuite est ce qu'elle est
conjoncturelle effectivement cette
inflation alors non elle n'est pas
exceptionnelle vous allez me dire quoi
comment est ce possible alors qu'on
parle dans cette hausse des prix partout
parce que ça dépend ce que vous regardez
là en effet vous avez les chiffres le
premier trimestre que l'on regarde dans
la pente quand le chi puisque ce serait
le chiffre de 2022 c'est la prévision
sur l'année pour voir que par exemple en
2021 l'inflation a été de 1,6 pour cent
on à l'elysée c'est à dire de janvier à
décembre 2021 quand on est un peu
d'inflation au début et beaucoup à la
fin eh bien on a une moyenne qui est en
dessous des 2% qui est la cible fixée
par la banque centrale européenne donc
2% là en effet on peut avoir une
inflation qui va être forte tirée par le
prix des énergies en raison donc la
crise et des crises ukrainienne des
crises géopolitiques et aussi de la
demande qui va continuer tout au cours
de l'année 2022 donc là on était on va
avoir sûrement nous dans nos prévisions
le premier le second trimestre vous
allez regarder hausse importante et
progressivement tout ce qui est pris
l'énergie et notamment du pétrole une
fois que les cris seront terminés et
d'autres facteurs
en effet assez conjoncturelles sont
dernière nous il y aura une baisse pour
avoir normalement sur les 2022 une
inflation qui seraient entre eux de 1,2
3,2 23% et donc légèrement au dessus de
la cible des 2% de la banque centrale
européenne alors une fois qu'on aime ça
vous allez dire que les chiffres
macroéconomiques et bien évidemment les
personnes les ménages qui nous écrivent
qu'ils disent est bien gentil mais c'est
parce qu'on ressemble
c'est toujours le problème pour le
ressenti les statistiques tout à fait en
effet un grand problème que l'on en
économie mais quand on regarde les
chiffres c'est ça et sur la question
conjoncturelle structurelle c'est ça qui
est tout à fait intéressant est
particulier avec cette crise c'est con à
la transition écologique derrière donc
au niveau du pétrole on voit en 2019 on
avait en fait des stocks de pétrole qui
était très conséquent une demande
mondiale qui avait tendance à baisser
d'où la crise l'effondrement qu'on ayant
même 2020 parce que les vendeurs ont
préféré vendre à perte parce qu'il y
avait plus de y avait plus de demandes
donc là une fois que les cris sont
derrière nous on risque d'avoir une
baisse un tassement de ses prix au
niveau du pétrole par contre étant des
cons à la transition écologique qui va
avoir un coût important notamment dans
la première phase les prix de
l'électricité et du gaz on continue
d'augmenter puisque progressivement tous
les processus productifs des entreprises
et notre consommation à se déporter vers
ces nouvelles énergies donc l'énergie et
la hausse des prix l'énergie continuera
d'être le moteur de l'inflation en
france après ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est ce qu'on verra les prochains mois
est-ce que ça va déborder au delà des 2
% et là en effet la banque centrale
européenne va peut-être intervenir en
voit déjà que c'est un peu l'idée parce
que poppy notamment à l'allemagne sont
beaucoup plus touchés que nous et là en
effet il pourrait y avoir un risque mais
pour l'instant en france on n'est pas
dans cette spirale inflationniste
pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas de hausse
générale des salaires dans tous les
secteurs pris certains c'est
peut-être une question qui est presque
une question idéologique que je voudrais
vous poser
à tous les trois est ce que vous faites
plus confiance aux marchés ou à l'état
pour trouver la solution je commence
avec vous mais je pense qu'il faut je
suis libéral oui et tout à fait après il
faut à pécresse elle incarne aussi une
droite sociale où l'état doit intervenir
pour limiter les externalités négatives
donc il faut que l'état intervienne mais
à sa juste mesure et en concertation
avec tous les acteurs et pas de façon
autoritaire donc ça je pensais la vision
idéologique que nous portons avec 100
voire matin
moi je crois qu'ils font ce savant
mélange des deux en réalité bien sûr il
faut à la fois je crois faire confiance
au marché parce qu'effectivement on voit
aujourd'hui prenez l hôtellerie cafés
restauration ils ont eu un problème et
non ils ont encore un problème énorme de
recrutement ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont augmenté leurs grilles de
salaires sans cesse croissant envoyait
besoin exactement ils ont besoin de
retrouver d'attractivité donc ils savent
faire par contre on en a d'autres
concrètement légaux la coiffure par
exemple qui a subi de plein fouet la
crise qui n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à
aboutir sur cette négociation sur ses
grilles de salaire alors même que là
encore on ad on a des femmes des hommes
qui ont des très bas salaires donc on
voit que il y en a certains qui peuvent
y arriver seul et peut marcher peut
effectivement dans certains cas y
arriver seul mais qu'il faudrait quand
même quelque part en cadres et non pas
pour obliger à mai pour inciter à aller
plus vite c'est pourquoi par exemple moi
je préconiserais de d'avoir une règle
qui dirait que une grille de salaires
conventionnelle ne pourrait pas avoir
plus d'un seul niveau au niveau du smic
et qu'il faudrait donner un délai
raisonnable qu'on fixerait d'une manière
ou d'une autre mais un délai raisonnable
pour donner le temps aux partenaires
sociaux de renégocier leurs grilles de
salaire si jamais elle était rattrapé
deux façons en plus et je crois que
c'est vraiment ça qui est important pour
moi c'est de détendre en fait cet espace
entre le smic et le salaire médian pour
que les salariés finalement qui ont des
petits salaires sorte de la trappe à bas
salaires qui a été créée par les
allégements de bas salaires de de
monsieur fillon à l'époque est
clairement c'est ce qui a fait que on a
aujourd'hui 70% des salariés dans cette
dans cette tranche qui sont payés
jusqu'à 1,6 smic seulement amine mbarki
est ce que vous faites confiance aux
j'allais dire au patron mais non aux
partenaires sociaux pour trouver
finalement la solution effectivement
secteur par secteur branche par branche
et ce qu'il faut forcément que ce soit
une verticalité il ya deux étés
reviennent de l'état non d'abord il ya 2
il ya deux étapes la première c'est la
négociation entre partenaires sociaux et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on propose on
veut faire en sorte que tous les
salaires en dessous de 2000 euros nets
soit augmentée via la négociation entre
les partenaires sociaux par branche
effectivement il ya des branches qui
sont plutôt dans une situation
économique confortable et dont les
salaires sont dynamiques et c'est une
bonne chose et puis à d'autres branches
où les salaires ne peuvent pas augmenter
notamment dont beaucoup dans l'économie
de services ou les difficiles d'une
année sur l'autre d'avoir des
augmentations de salaires et donc du
coup là l'état doit intervenir avec le
salaire minimum avec l'impulsion de
l'état peut donner dans les négociations
par branches mais il faut être clair
s'il ya des millions de personnes qui
ont vu leur fiche de paye resté
identique d'un mois sur l'autre d'une
année sur l'autre à un moment donné
c'est à l'état d'intervenir
en fait sacré et c'est tout le problème
je pense que madame elsie pourra le dire
mieux que moi encore quand vous
augmentez les salaires comme ça il faut
bien que les entreprises puissent les
payer donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'elles augmentent leurs prix mais vous
savez donc se dire que
inflation mauvais image et donc vous
rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle une boucle
prix salaires non et c'est ça qui est
absolument dans par exemple reprise n'a
jamais élevé juste les missions à venir
il ya beaucoup de secteurs dans lesquels
aujourd'hui entre les hausses de
matières premières et le fait qu'il
n'arrive pas à passer l'intégralité des
augmentations de prix qu'ils devraient
au contraire ils rognent sur leurs
marges mais ce qui est très clair c'est
que si on rentre effectivement dans une
logique d'augmentation
immédiate de toute la population d'une
augmentation générale alors
effectivement on va rentrer dans cette
boucle prix salaires ils sont en train
de rentrer dedans aux états unis et
c'est dramatique parce qu'effectivement
vous courrez finalement après le
fait des réformes à côté pour diminuer
le coût du travail est nous cesserons
pas très ferme sur les relations
sociales elles sont déjà assez vite au
niveau du smic las vegas et isation le
poignet assaillants français c'est
évalué à environ 3 points de pib donc
c'est un coup énorme pour les
entreprises sept bureaux de cette
protection sociale à ce moment là parce
que moi j'ai dû votre programme et j'ai
vu cette mesure n'a pas prise sur le
doublement des salaires pour les
professeurs c'est qu'il n'y a jamais de
financement à côté d un souci de la
réforme des retraites un exemple
d'économies de l'état qui permet de
financer sauf que si vous baissez les
cotisations vous mangez déjà quasiment
tout est comme vous enlevez le forfait
social sur la participante à corps sur
les familles encore ces propos en disant
on peut pas avoir des mesures
structurelles pour répondre à la
situation on peut pas se dire d'une
augmentation salariale significative des
salariés qui n'ont pas vu leur fiche de
paye évolué d'une année sur l'autre
parce qu'on a peur d'une inflation qui
je le rappelle jusqu'à il ya quelques
mois était quasiment stagnante depuis
2000 très 2012
entre change
sandra mottin passe pour tient donner la
parole à geoffroy roux de bézieux la
question c'est que pense le patronat
d'une augmentation du smic c'était sur
france 2 aux 4 vérités 25 janvier
dernier une augmentation massive du smic
même si ça paraît résoudre le problème
du port n'est en réalité à terme sa
fabrique du chômage donc c'est pas une
mesure intelligente une hausse du smic
plombe tel l'emploi pour répondre à
cette question j'appelle laurent mauriac
à me rejoindre le rédacteur en chef de
brief me bonsoir laurent vous êtes notre
partenaire dans cette campagne short à
la présidentielle bienvenus le
gouvernement justifie de ne pas donner
un coup de pouce au smic par un risque
de destruction d'emplois oui alors le
smic augmente de 2 façons
automatiquement en fonction de
l'inflation et du pouvoir d'achat et
parfois s'ajoute ce qu'on appelle le
coup de pouce ce qui est pris sur
décision du gouvernement et le dernier
remonte à 2012 alors elisabeth bornes la
ministre du travail a justifié l'absence
de coup de pouce cette année par les
répercussions possibles sur le nombre
d'emplois et voici ce qu'elle en dise
est sûre ses news en décembre on a fait
le choix depuis le début du quinquennat
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat en
augmentant la prime d'activité en
supprimant certaines cotisations c'est à
dire pour augmenter leurs revenus sans
peser sur le coût du travail ce qui peut
détruire des emplois donc c'est ce qui
nous amène à suivre les recommandations
des économistes spécialistes du smic qui
ne recommande pas un coup de pouce donc
ce ne doit pas faire de coup de pouce je
vous le confirme
alors il ya effectivement un groupe
d'économistes spécialisés oui depuis
2009 un groupe d'experts remet chaque
année au gouvernement un rapport dans
lequel il présente une recommandation et
en 2021 une fois encore il a déconseillé
tout coup de pouce en mettant en avant
le risque de freiner la reprise de
l'emploi et voici ce que les experts
écrivait dans leur rapport publié en
décembre je cite une hausse du smic au
delà des mécanismes de revalorisation
automatique risquerait d'être
préjudiciable à l'emploi des personnes
les plus vulnérables alors sur quoi
s'appuie pour énoncer un tel risque
alors sur deux choses une théorie
économique et des études alors la
théorie économique c'est la théorie dite
classique elle dit que si vous obligez
les chefs d'entreprise à augmenter les
bas salaires vous alourdissait le coût
du travail et ça peut inciter les
entreprises à diminuer le nombre
d'emplois proposés et alors le groupe
d'experts sur le smic s'appuie aussi sur
des études internationales qui montre
pour certaines un effet négatif sur
l'emploi mais en france la dernière
étude d'ampleur remonte à 2012 et elle
estimé qu'un coup de pouce au smic de 1
% entraînerait au total la destruction
de 2100 emplois donc c'est un effet
plutôt faible à l'échelle d'un pays
comme la france alors depuis ça peut
paraître surprenant mais on n'a pas de
données solides plus fraîches et le
groupe d'experts le déplore on y verra
peut-être plus clair bientôt puisque une
étude vient d'être lancée par france
stratégie un organisme qui est rattaché
à matignon merci beaucoup merci à
laurent mauriac rédacteur en chef de
brief mais c'est quand même étonnant
cette histoire sent un motard il n'y a
pas d'études récentes il y en ait qui
est alors de la banque d'espagne qui est
son origine la en 2021 mais qui est
intéressante oui m'enfin pas ce qu'on va
chercher des infos chez nos voisins
espagnols c'est que les espagnols en
fait ils ont fait une hausse massive du
smic ils ont fait en plus 22% oui ça a
détruit entre 94 milles et 175 mille
emplois en espagne ils ont pas bien il à
niveau smic qui était beaucoup plus bas
que le nôtre pages qui pouvaient ce
compte bien sûr mais concrètement ce
rattrapage ça détruit de l'emploi vous
dites entre compte donc j'ai entre 94
milles et 175 je vais pas me la rejeter
large mais on est quasiment à 100 mille
emplois on peut se dire détruits il ya
une autre chose que dit le rapport des
experts du smi qui est extrêmement
intéressante c'est celle justement cette
question de la revalorisation parce que
finalement regarder ce qui a été obligé
de faire elisabeth bord dispose ce qui a
obligé de faire le gouvernement tous les
ans c'est justifier pourquoi il n'y a
pas de coup de pouce là franchement
j'aimerais que le politique reprenne la
main j'aimerais que le politique
reprenne la main et décide de
l'augmentation du smic plutôt que de
laisser faire un calcul technocratique
tel qu'il est fait aujourd'hui parce que
concrètement
aujourd'hui je vois bien dans tous les
programmes finalement que ce soit à
droite ou à gauche tout le monde propose
une augmentation des salaires tout le
monde va augmenter le smic jusqu'à 1400
euros mais même 1415 donc c'est la
surenchère reprenons pour allons-y
vraiment décidons que ce sont les
politiques qui vont décider c'est une
excitation du smic c'est le
droit social et je vous mets un change
et recommandations de ce groupe macron
parce que vous représentez
moi je dis aujourd'hui je m'appuie sur
le groupe jeudi que je trouve que la
proposition des experts du smic est
extrêmement intéressante et qu'elle
mérite vraiment qu'on s'y arrête à
méditer le tout le monde veut changer le
suit le rapport du groupe d'experts il a
il est jeune il n'est pas obligatoire il
peut ne pas être respectés en 2012 il ya
un coup de pouce de gouvernement
hollande alors que le rapport ne le
recommanderais pas sur la question du
smic bien sûr que ça peut détruire de
l'emploi très bien mais la théorie
économique elle dit aussi autre chose
elle dit dans un contexte économique
favorable
la hausse du smic eu de plaine entraîné
une hausse encore davantage de
situations économiques mais ne pas
descendre en page suivante regardez même
regardez regardez regardez jamais vos
dires je vais reprendre l'argument de
rambouillet non mais la dernière étude
2012 un coot d'un coup de pouce de 1%
ses 2100 emplois avance et d'henri pour
les 2100 famille un jeu je minimise sur
un épi à l'échelle d'un pays est par
ailleurs ça dépend des secteurs ça peut
être détruit et recréer juste après tu
donc en différé sur caen joue ainsi
pardon de vous contredire mais andrade
11 remploi le smic brut est à 10,57
euros l'heure au royaume uni n'est pas
un pays marxiste il est à
10,63 euros de l'heure en allemagne ils
ont décidé de passer le smic de 9 euros
l'heure à 12 euros l'heure tous ces pays
là en fait nous dépasse en termes de
smic et nous on a encore en train de se
dire simple on est encore oui bah oui
nous les sanctions et cotisations
sociales et non la déco exclusive les
cotisations sociales effectivement ne
sont pas réduites dans ces pays que chez
nous elles le sont n'y a pas que ça
quasiment au
niveau du smic donc ça veut dire
aujourd'hui à les gens qui tuent
aujourd'hui augmenter le smic est
nécessaire parce que depuis presque
quinze ans les salaires des 10 à 15% les
plus modestes a stagné alors que le
salaire des 10 à 15 % les plus aisés lui
a augmenté il faut payer 7 ont alors là
il ya une augmentation mais les
mécaniques avec l'inflation et
deux fois le smic ça c'est la gestion de
votre candidate ça fait 2000 791 euros
jusqu'à
1800 euros effectivement est par exemple
lettre + 3 % dès cet été c'est à peu
près 500 en plus par an pour un salarié
au smic mais ce que je veux dire tout à
l'heure vous m'avez un peu titillé sur
cette fameuse concertation oui en fait
elle est importante parce qu'on ce qui
fait qu'on m'ait l'augmentation du smic
les destructions d'emplois c'est qu'on
regarde que ce sujet là mais il faut
mettre d'autres choses dans la balance
si on grand dans une discussion avec les
entreprises il faut mettre dedans la
libéralisation du temps de travail la
baisse des impôts de production je le
redis la débureaucratisation et tout ça
pour aussi baisser les coûts des
entreprises et donc ça ne peut pas être
vu juste par l'entrée augmentation du
smic mais dans le cadre d'une discussion
merci de me laisser finir plus globale
sur tout un tas de sujets qui baissent
aussi les coûts des entreprises un tout
petit mot et ensuite en mode depuis tout
à l'heure on parle de l'impact du smic
sur les entreprises il faut le prendre
en compte ma juste on rappelle l'impact
de la stagnation salariale pour des
millions de françaises et français
bonsergent ne vais pas oui mais on parle
aussi un argument sort d'un vote à
la question effectivement 2
que vous posez finalement c'est
quand on regarde ce qu'il ya autour du
smic alors moi je tiens à rappeler
d'abord que la prime d'activité on est
passé de 1 milliard à 4 milliards donc
les français ont massivement recours
mais au-delà de ça encore une fois ce
que vous faites c'est compresser des
salaires et c'est enlever des
perspectives à des gens et donc tout ça
sans compter alors avec votre par
exemple ce que vous dites sur le temps
de travail honnêtement les ordonnances
on a voté en tout début de quinquennat
permettent déjà à toute entreprise de
faire ce qu'elle veut sur son temps à
béthune avec des à cause d'entreprises
alors qu'on aimait ça veut dire summum
de je vous assure qu'il ya eu énormément
d'accord y compris d'ailleurs dans des
tpe et dans des pme ce qui est très
intéressant maintenant si on veut
vraiment agir si on veut vraiment agir
pour tout le monde moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin effectivement
on l'a dit de justice sociale la justice
sociale elle passe aujourd'hui je crois
encore plus peut-être qu'un autre jour
quand on voit les résultats de total où
tout le monde s'est exclamé c'est un
marronnier de l'année à chaque fois
qu'on a les dividendes versés par les
entreprises du cac 40 tout le monde
s'offusque
bien créons dividende du travail
fillon dividendes aux salariés oui allez
au zoo du son c'est le partage de la
valeur faisons en sorte effectivement
que de manière correcte tout le monde
puisse bénéficier du temps mais on va y
revenir là dessus je voudrais quand même
entendre de nouveau and social sis
peut-être pour rappeler une évidence
parce que là on est beaucoup sur que
peut faire l'état c'est logique on est
encore pas une présidentielle mais c'est
peut-être un peu d'abord le marché qui
décide non oui on aime rappeler quelques
mécanismes économiques que l'arbre ne
parle pas du tout est sûre
la fixation des salaires une personne
dont personne n'a parlé c'est quand même
le terme productivité aujourd'hui votre
salaire il est ni par rapport à quoi par
rapport à la valeur ajoutée que vous
créez donc c'est ça la productivité la
valeur ajoutée créée c'est ça qui fixe
le prix et qui fixe un salaire c'est pas
ex nihilo ont décidé de fixer un prix
comme ça qui correspond à rien donc ça
ce sont des mécanismes économiques on ne
peut pas décider comme ça de ne pas
parler de ça pour parler de la fixation
des salaires c'est absolument centrale
et qu'est ce qui se passe qui se passe
quand effet le processus productif en
france et très basée sur les services
qui crée moins de deux gains de
productivité donc si aujourd'hui on veut
augmenter les salaires il faut vraiment
augmenté en gal et donc est sur des
structures et du chant des sur des
secteurs on n'est plus sûr de la
compétitivité hors coûts et c'est comme
ça a vraiment que vous augmenterez les
salaires parce que vous serez dans une
compétition où vous vendez du haut de
gamme donc que vous allez une valeur
ajoutée donner aux salaires qui est plus
importante parce que ce que vous
produisez créer plus de valeur donc ça
c'est vraiment un élément très important
et puis l'autre aspect c'est le smic là
aussi on a un débat qui est complètement
franco français comme si on était seul
au monde et les rapports d'experts
qu'elle explique puisque c'était aussi
un élément c'est la compétitivité nous
ne sommes pas seuls au monde le sol va
non relié aux autres pays du monde on
compte quand on augmente les smic oui ça
peut avoir un impact important sur la
consommation quand vous êtes en teintes
deux reprises parce que plus votre
salaire est bas plus les consommer et
donc remis dans l'économie réelle il
n'est pas épargné par contre ça peut
avoir un impact sur la compétitivité
notamment en effet pour les salariés qui
ont moins de valeur ajoutée produite on
l'a vu dans l'industrie 1 c'est ce qui
s'est passé en france en fin de partie
dans les phénomènes de
désindustrialisation est donc là encore
est bien c'est de compétitivité peut
avoir des impacts et détruire de
l'emploi donc encore une fois ne
raisonnons pas juste en franco français
mais au niveau global et voir l'impact
que cela peut avoir sur les travailleurs
et les salariés merci anne sophie et
lætitia vouliez sur cet enjeu on va
élargir un petit peu du pouvoir d'achat
vouliez revenir sur la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
vous la mettez au crédit
du bilan du quinquennat ce n'est pas moi
ta maman s'il vous plaît je reste
toujours neutre maintenant c'est le
vrai ces derniers baromètres cofidis en
fait c'est un baromètre annuel sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français qui a posé
donc une question est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'était la dixième
édition là c'était septembre dernier ils
ont fait une rétrospective des dix
dernières années dont vous voyez c'est
quand même il ya un traître un grand
nombre de français qui sont interrogés
sur les dix dernières années la question
elle est simple quand vous repensez aux
principales mesures d'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat des français depuis 2012
laquelle de ces mesures a eu le plus
d'impact sur votre pouvoir d'achat plus
d'une personne sur deux a répondu la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
question est grande devant une liste
fermée avec une liste mais vraiment très
grande et mais loin devant c'est à dire
que ça c'est vraiment la toute première
mesure qui apparaît et ensuite la
deuxième elle est loin derrière 24 % de
réponses c'est le reste à charge 0 pour
les soins optique dentaire et d'audition
voyez mais c'est vrai que c'est un
marqueur très fort des manuels macro qui
a permis d'installer sa notoriété au
départ dans sa campagne sa popularité
quand il est en campagne quand il arrive
aussi à l'elysée puisque tout de suite
il a mis en place évidemment et puis
comme n'est pas terminée cette mesure
puisqu'elle a été repoussée elle dépend
du ça dépend d'eux niveau de revenus de
rémunération est en fait en vérité n'est
pas totalement supprimées on reçoit une
taxe d'habitation est le fils fait bien
les choses si vous dites voilà voilà
courriel vous aurait coûté s'il n'y
avait pas eu la réforme exactement ça a
été fait aussi sur les bulletins de
salaire quand on a des blessés les
cotisations concerne déjà 80% français
20% des français restants seront
concernés en 2023 donc je termine juste
comme ça peut-être une mesure d'entrer
en campagne pour le président sortant
oui on verra bien alexandre bon je vous
mettais effectivement cette mesure au
crédit du bilan du quinquennat de m je
suis
élue municipale donc je vois aussi
l'impact qui se voit moins à long terme
pour nos concitoyens que les films et
les mairies qui n'ont plus ces moyens là
pour investir dans les salles propres
est pas du tout c'est l'assuré sinon les
genres entre les chars comité sur cette
mesure a dit j'avais vu venir c'est que
la chaise de ce type de mesures font
toujours très plaisir forcément un
chèque on en a eu pas mal 25 milliards
de chèques depuis cet été ça fait
toujours plaisir après moi je
m'interroge en responsabilité en mère de
famille sur l'impact sur les générations
futures et comment on finance tout cela
l'argent public n'est pas de l'argent de
monopoly est donc parfois bien sûr je
comprends que cette mesure plaisent aux
français mais je trouve qu'elle a des
impacts à long terme assez néfaste et
donc
donc vous mettez pas vraiment au crédit
des manuels macron cet été 20 milliards
c'est justement parce qu'on a compensé
les communes à l'euro près que monnaie
pour l'avenir ont su grâce à l'avenir on
sait pas si
c'est dur
bon allez une autre proposition elle
vient de votre candidate mines mbarki
c'est cette proposition d'anne hidalgo
instaurer un écart maximal de 1 à 20
dans les entreprises entre la
rémunération la plus basse et la
rémunération la plus haute est ce que
pour vous c'est une réponse à ce qu'on a
vu c'est à quoi on a assisté là depuis
quelques mois on s'est rendu compte que
d'un enrichissement des plus riches
finalement pendant cette crise sanitaire
alors au delà de la crise sanitaire il y
as depuis au moins 20 ans un
enrichissement très élevé des salaires
les plus élevés par rapport à ceux des
plus modestes et donc il ya un besoin là
on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'intervention et à marcher là il ya un
besoin d'intervention et je précise
juste que la mesure elle n'interdit pas
les salaires au-delà de 1 à 20 dans
l'entreprise simplement ils ne sont plus
déductibles de l'impôt sur les sociétés
alors qu'aujourd'hui elles le sont
pourquoi est-ce qu'on installe sa
décision on arrive à 25 1380 euros si on
regarde la rémunération des grands
patrons on en est très très très très
loin et par ailleurs beaucoup se
rémunère autrement que par la
rémunération du travail en capital et
c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on propose
cette mesure tout simplement parce qu'
il ne peut pas y avoir d'entreprises qui
fonctionne correctement si ya pas une
cohésion dans une flèche les salaires et
entre les salariés qu'est ce qui
justifie qu à un salarié gagne parfois
300 fois moins que son patron pas grand
chose il donc il ya un moment donné il
faudra ajouter de l'humain et de la
rationalité dans les écarts de salaires
certains proposent autres 1,12 à 1,15 là
l'idée de se dire un vin c'est
parfaitement justifiée entre le patron
et le salarié qui est le plus bas de
l'échelle des salaires j'ai pas compris
ou ailleurs le plus élevé ce sera 25
millions 20 x 20 x
j'ai pris le smic donc si on multiplie
par vincent tous les salaires qui sont
au-delà de 25 mille et qui peuvent
parfaitement exister simplement ils ne
sont pas déductibles de l'impôt sur les
sociétés comme celle qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais je commence à il vous
semble un matin moi j'aime pas bien je
n'aime pas beaucoup les règles
moralisatrice par contre ce que je sais
c'est que dans 99 % des pme et tpe en
france aujourd'hui c'est déjà le cas et
que je vois là envisager sur les
entreprises du cac 40 ou même du sbf 120
qui sont pauvres qui sont certainement
celles qui sont dans ce cas là comment
est ce que vous allez justifier alors
que vous avez des dirigeants de classe
mondiale aussi qui gère des groupes
mondiaux mention que ben voilà on va
prendre qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
on va réellement dire encore nos
prélèvements obligatoires je sais c'est
la spécialité de la gauche nous
attaquons trop sage est simple je vois
comment justifier le salaire entre
l'écart de salaire entre 20 et 300
bakambu gens pensent que quand vous
dirigez une multinationale qui est coté
vous prenez des risques vous voilà et ça
serait mieux alors et quand vous
cette prévision très clivée quand on
essaye de se positionner ce savoir pour
qui on va voter par exemple je me mets à
la place de tous les français là qu'ils
sont en train de se poser la question ça
ces deux modèles de société très
différents ces deux visions
alisation c'est une
taxation des hauts salaires quel qu'il
soit on sait très bien ce qui se passe
après les gens viennent plus reste plus
dans notre pays on est sûr de ça on en
est sûr maintenant on
préfère je suis d'accord en revanche sur
cette volonté de rendre le capitalisme a
plus inclusif dans une logique gagnant
gagnant entre le salarié les entreprises
mais nous on préfère passer par
l'actionnariat salarié par exemple donc
des choses ont été faites mais
aujourd'hui à peu près 2% du capital des
entreprises qui est détenu par les
salariés nous on veut arriver jusqu'à
10% mieux partager la valeur
actuellement est aussi maître développer
la participation avec un dividende
salariés donc on préfère cette
incitation là en donnant plus les moyens
aux salariés d'être en phase avec les
reichel leur entreprise plutôt que de
mettre des contraintes
anne-sophie aussi sur 7 cet écart entre
le plus bas et le plus haut salaire si
là aussi si on n'est pas franco-français
comment comment vous l'analysez
alors oui hein c'est vrai qu'il ya une
augmentation des inégalités depuis 10 15
ans après là aussi quand vous regardez
en france on a un système redistributif
est quand même très performante et quand
vous regardez les inégalités avant et
après une distribution en est l'un des
pays européens le système redistributif
marche le mieux on a le moins des cas
donc c'est plutôt assez positif et aussi
on parle beaucoup et toujours de la
valeur ajoutée donc là j'ai ce que
j'essayais de mettre en avant et
l'impact et ça en effet une économie ce
qu'il faut regarder dans les salaires
dans justement cette valeur ajoutée la
part des salaires est elle est là bas on
court en effet les dividendes et les
actionnaires et comment utiliser cet
argent cet argent est réinvesti et on
voit aujourd'hui que l'investissement
des entreprises est vraiment une matrice
de la reprise avec la consommation des
ménages et bien c'est plutôt
très positif donc là aussi je pense
qu'il faut faire attention et encore
regarder ce qui se passe au niveau
international au niveau d'un système
redistributif il est globalement très
performant
j'ai regardé le patron le mieux payé de
france y gagne 1000 fois le smic et vous
pensez que c'est normal une fois moi je
pose la question est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est normal est ce que un grand
patron qui a une vision qui impulsent la
stratégie d'un groupe quand ce goût un
groupe dans ce groupe mais si dans ce
groupe
gagnent beaucoup d'argent est ce que
c'est justifié qui gagne 1000 fois le
smic donc mille fois plus que le salaire
le plus bas l'entreprise veut nettement
ça ne me choque pas comme ça ne me
choque pas parce que ces gens là sont
des gens qui sont qui ont une
responsabilité énorme de tous ses
emplois d'une vision stratégique qui
sont souvent d'ailleurs on soutien des
états aussi ne faut pas oublier regarder
ton critique total mais personne ne leur
a demandé de faire des feux un coup de
pouce pour le gaz de leurs clients les
plus fragiles enfin je crois que ces
gens l'assurance
ils ont ils ont un poids stratégique
dans les pays dans lesquels ils sont
implantés qui est extrêmement fort et
donc je vois saura que le salaire du
chef de l'état j'en sais rien je sais
logique
la logique que vous que vous amenez est
aussi inverse dans l'autre sens la
personne au smic qui met deux heures
pour aller à son boulot le matin et deux
heures pour revenir qui galèrent pour
finir ses fins de mois et pour remplir
son frigo est ce que quand elle voit son
patron gagner mille fois plus elle se
dit pas que c'est injuste je pense que
sincèrement moi je pense que si je vous
dit rien
c'est totalement mois de salaire en plus
grâce à la participation ils ont deux à
trois mois de salaire en plus non je
crois que le salarié tué total d'abord
elle est fière d'être dans son
entreprise et en plus il est content que
sont pas chauds et bien parce qu'on
passe que grâce à tottenham c'est parce
que c'est sûrement donner leurs chiffres
de dividende aujourd'hui voilà et c'est
terminé merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci anne
sophie aussi pour votre expertise c'est
toujours intéressant de prendre ce ce
recul je vous dis
à lundi pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public